regardez ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
samsung vient de présenter ces nouveaux
Samsung Galaxy S23 bien évidemment S23
année 2023 vous l'aurez compris depuis
2020 ils ont fait la blague ils ont
dormi ça marche comme ça on sait à quel
moment c'est smartphone sont sortis
alors trois nouveaux smartphones on
regarde le même liner l'idée aujourd'hui
c'est de vous présenter rapidement ces
trois produits vous connaissiez
l'essentiel et on approfondira d'ici
quelques jours on sera un test une prise
en main on fera des photos donc pensez à
bien vous abonner c'est pas déjà le cas
vous cliquez sur le bouton rouge s'il
est rouge c'est que vous n'êtes pas
abonné c'est pas bien et si il est pas
rouge actionnaient la cloche sur les
factionnés c'est pas bien voilà vous
êtes prêt allez on y va
[Musique]
je vous arrête là vous pouvez bien
évidemment acheter votre smartphone
directement et notamment sur le site de
Samsung une fois de plus le lien est
dans la description mais vous pouvez
également venir le louer c'est justement
aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est réalisée
en partenariat avec un ex mobile qui
alors ici je vous montre le S22 parce
qu'au moment où j'ai tourné cette vidéo
les Galaxy S23 c'était pas encore
officialisé ils le sont désormais mais
vous les trouverez donc directement sur
le site de Next mobile et je vous mets
bien évidemment tous les liens pour
aller voir sur Next mobile vous allez
voir c'est super intéressant pourquoi
parce que je donne l'exemple avec le S22
vous venez choisir votre Smartphone vous
choisissez la couleur vous choisissez la
capacité et ensuite vous pouvez venir
prendre votre smartphone un tarif
intéressant vous pourrez par exemple
venir louer votre galaxie S23 à 39 euros
90 € par mois ou bien le S23 ultra à
59,90 € par mois ça vous évite de venir
l'acheter c'est une location sans
engagement comme ça vous pouvez
découvrir le smartphone vous amusez avec
s'il vous plaît vous gardez s'il vous
plaît pas pour en changer ou passer
autre chose je ne vous cache pas que je
pense que dans le cas des galaxies S23
ils vont vous plaire regarder la suite
de la vidéo et vous comprendrez tout et
on se parle bien ici une fois de plus
d'une offre sans engagement en plus de
ça sont inclus ici c'est écrit ici
l'assurance casse est vole et tous les
12 mois et ça c'est vachement bien vous
pouvez venir changer votre smartphone
par exemple je passe du Galaxy S23 au
Galaxy S24 sortira l'année prochaine et
bien vous pourrez changer votre
smartphone tout ça au même tarif et
toujours sans engagement et en plus ici
avec ce S22 vous avez une coque et un
protège écran offert bien évidemment
vous avez les garanties garanti toute
panne couverture mondiale pas de
franchise bien évidemment l'assurance
casse et oxydation casse accidentelle
oxydation accidentelle dommage causé par
tiers et ici il y a zéro franchise et
une assurance pour le vol on se parle
ici de vol avec agression ou effraction
mais également de volatir ou à la
sauvette et ici vous avez une franchise
de 150 euros pour moi les assurances un
truc important et rassurant parce que si
vous cassez par exemple l'écran de votre
smartphone ça peut venir chiffrer
jusqu'à 400 euros jusqu'à 400 euros en
plus de ça next mobile a une démarche
éco-responsable regardez il voulait
écrire ici nous redonnons une seconde
vie au smartphone en fin de location le
smartphone qui arrivera chez vous sera
neuf et une fois que vous l'aurez
utilisé et quand vous le rendrez et bien
ce smartphone sera reconditionné en
France avec un circuit court et il
pourra être ensuite reloué en
reconditionné ici parce que oui c'est
Dex mobile on a également à la location
des smartphones reconditionnés et en
plus de ça accrochez-vous next mobile
est une entreprise française et ça c'est
chouette j'ai un code promo pour
vous mobile dans les
meilleurs règlements avec le code Mr
gros 30 je vous invite donc à venir
découvrir next mobile et envisager
pourquoi pas devenir louer votre
smartphone au lieu de venir l'acheter
d'ailleurs s'il vous intéresse je vous
mets le lien en bas dans la description
et merci annexe mobile d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo 3 nouveaux
smartphones Samsung Galaxy S23 S23 plus
un peu plus grand mais regarde la même
idée puis le S23 ultra qui est
l'héritier de la gamme note on a
vraiment ces trois produits qui évoluent
et surtout la grosse évolution et je
vous l'ai déjà dit il y a quelques temps
c'est quoi et bien c'est le retour le
grand retour en fanfare de Qualcomm avec
son Snapdragon 8 GN2 alors je vous ai
déjà fait une vidéo pour vous le
présenter mais en fait quoi comme c'est
un très gros focus sur l'intelligence
artificielle on vient titiller se
rapprocher un peu des puces de Apple ici
on a beaucoup plus de performances on va
aller plus loin en termes d'autonomie on
ira beaucoup plus loin en termes de
photos vous allez voir surtout sur le
ultra c'est intéressant avec un très
gros capteur de 200 mégapixels mais
avant d'approfondir ces différents
points on va déjà commencer par regarder
un peu la tronche qu'ils ont parce qu'il
y a une très très jolie évolution alors
venez voir ici on arrive sur le S23 S23
on dira c'est la base oui et non mon
petit lapin le S23 en fait c'est le 23
plus c'est quasiment la même chose on va
voir une différence au niveau de la
taille de l'écran on va voir une
différence au niveau du format un peu
plus grand bien évidemment avoir une
différence au niveau de la taille de la
batterie mais sinon c'est sensiblement
la même chose c'est le même esprit en
tout cas donc soit vous avez des petites
minimes il voulait pas tout le trop gros
le S23 ira très bien soit vous avez mimi
un peu plus grosse et vous voulez un
écran un peu plus grand vous allez sur
le S23 plus voilà ça c'est l'idée donc
ça c'est le S23 alors vous voyez tout de
suite la particularité qu'on a avec ces
S23 S23 plus versus les S22 S22+ et bien
c'est design qui est venu être
totalement uniformiser sur la gamme on
est dans l'idée de ce qu'on avait
l'année dernière avec le S22 ultra
c'est-à-dire on n'a plus la petite
partie qu'on avait sur le côté qui
faisait vraiment différencier le module
photo du reste du dos du smartphone
comme ça ça marche c'est joli c'est bien
c'est pratique et surtout les trois
produits se ressemblent donc quand vous
les voyez dos il y en a pas un qui va
juré par rapport à l'autre donc ça c'est
vachement sympa donc ça c'est le S23 à
la suite de celui-là arrive le S 23 plus
alors je vous le dis c'est la même
histoire la différence et qui va être un
peu plus grand vous savez quoi j'ai pris
des notes je suis en très bonne élève
alors je vais vous donner les détails
tout de suite pour vous ayez un peu des
infos que vous rendre compte en fait sur
le 10-23 vous êtes sur un 6,1 pouces sur
le S23 plus vous êtes sur un 6,6 pouces
dans tous les cas on est sur du full HD+
le ratio de pixel par pouce sera un peu
différent mais globalement ça change pas
grand chose alors ici on a pas de dalle
ltpo on a un taux de rafraîchissement
variable on va jusqu'à 120 Hertz mais on
passe de 48 jusqu'à 120 Hz à la
différence et on va aller voir par
rapport au ultra qui est juste derrière
recrute mon petit lapin le ultra il est
là alors le ultra il raconte une
histoire qui est quand même relativement
différente je vous parle tout de suite
de la dalle parce qu'on était dessus
l'écran va être un peu plus grand on est
sur du 6,8 pouces résolution supérieure
quad HD plus on se parle d'une dalle
ltpo qui nous permet effectivement de
monter jusqu'à 12 comme les sept petits
copains mais de descendre jusqu'à un
Hertz alors ça vous servir à quoi et
bien lorsque vous êtes sur un allwrez on
display comme là typiquement il y a pas
grand chose dessus ça c'est vachement
pratique et bien on va descendre au
niveau du nombre d'images par seconde
pour venir consommer moins au niveau de
la batterie donc en fait l'idée ici
c'est que vous allez avoir un smartphone
qui sera moins énergivore qui aura une
plus grosse batterie et qui avec le
nouveau stand dragon 8 gène 2 vous
permettra d'aller plus loin en tout cas
c'est la promesse et on verra si ça se
confirme lors du test et le truc est
très cool c'est que quel que soit les
que vous avez là vous montez jusqu'à
000 sur des smartphones qui sont très
lumineux en extérieur donc si vous
voulez regarder une série sur la plage
en été vous pouvez le faire après c'est
très bizarre de venir regarder une série
sur la page en été allez plutôt jouer au
ballon mais surtout ce S23 va raconter
une histoire qui est différente il est
le digne héritier de la gamme note feu
la gamme note qui est décédé il y a
quelques années avec un espèce intégré
alors le truc qui est assez marrant ici
si vous voulez c'est que le Spain c'est
exactement le même que celui que vous
aviez l'année dernière enfin presque
exactement parce que Samsung est venu
bosser son design et à modifier
légèrement les contours un écran qui
sera un poil plus plat un format un peu
plus carré un peu moins arrondi ça joue
vraiment à pas grand chose mais si vous
étiez pas totalement raccord avec le S22
ultra peut-être que le S23 ultra vous
plaira en tout cas sachez que toutes les
fonctionnalités que vous avez avec le
S22 ultra au niveau du s-pn vous les
conservez ici sur le S23 ultra donc à
part vraiment de gros changements ici
quel que soit le modèle que vous allez
choisir vous aurez exactement la même
base de couleur à savoir une petite
couleur noire comme ça qui est très
jolie on a également du crème bon en
fait c'est du noir et du blanc mais ils
aiment bien mettre des noms c'est plutôt
sympathique retrouver toujours le
lavande que Samsung adore vous présenter
et d'ailleurs vous pouvez venir les
assortir avec d'autres produits
notamment côté lavande avec votre montre
avec vos Galaxy buzz bref vous pouvez le
faire et vous avez cette couleur verte
vers un peu kaki très sympa que je
trouve très joli personnellement ça que
j'ai préféré aujourd'hui et en plus de
ça vous avez des couleurs exclusives
vous pouvez retrouver sur le site de
SAMSUNG.com une fois de plus je vous
mets le lien juste en bas dans la
description allez jeter un petit coup
d'œil alors j'ai tout noté parce que
j'ai pas pris par cœur sur le S23 et S23
plus vous aurez une couleur graphite et
une couleur line couleur un peu citron
très pêchue sympa bien pour le printemps
et l'été ça ça va pas tarder à arriver
d'ailleurs préparé vous et on retrouve
en plus pour le ultra une couleur bleu
ciel et une couleur rouge je voudrais
qu'on vienne 2 secondes sur cette
histoire de processeur qui change alors
vous le saviez jusqu'à l'année dernière
retrouvez les exinos enfin pas
réellement j'étais l'année dernière
parce que sur le marché américain
canadien on avait des processeurs de
Qualcomm c'était vraiment dédié à ce
marché là nous dans le reste du monde et
dans l'Europe on avait les exinos c'est
quand même une petite différence de perf
même si ce que fait ça me saoule avec
ses xénon stress malgré tout très bien
alors pour la petite histoire si on
remonte loin en arrière faut savoir
qu'on avait déjà des processeurs de
Qualcomm sur la gamme S tu es sur le S6
qui était le dernier avoir effectivement
un processeur de Qualcomm instant dragon
et puis après finito l'escargot jusqu'à
cette année ça revient ça c'est cool
alors le truc qui est intéressant est-ce
que nous dit ici Samsung c'est que ils
ont travaillé main dans la main vous
voyez on se tient comme ça avec quoi
comme pour venir développer leur pas
réellement développé parce que le
processeur le dragon 8 GN2 est
totalement développé par quoi comme mais
il y a une adaptation qui a été faite du
8e 2 pour qu'il soit totalement optimisé
par rapport ici à ses smartphones donc
j'ai vraiment hâte de venir voir sur le
terrain ce que ça raconte parce que je
vous refais très rapidement ce qui est
génial avec ces types de processeur et
surtout celui-là qui a d'être vraiment
bien une fois de plus axé sur
l'intelligence artificielle avec plein
de nouvelles fonctionnalités qui
pourraient être vraiment intéressantes
donc avoir à tester et bien c'est que
vous allez avoir un gain de performance
au niveau graphique au niveau calcul
bien évidemment mais un gain au niveau
des photos on sait qu'avec le syndr
dragon 8 GN2 on peut aller jusqu'à
capteur maximum de 200 mégapixels autant
vous dire que Samsung ils sont pas
privés de le mettre sur le modèle ultra
donc on va jusqu'à un capteur de 200
mégapixels mais ça je vous le dis dans
quelques instants donc de meilleures
photos meilleur calcul bien évidemment
meilleur autonomie fatalement même sur
des grosses batteries il faut qu'on ait
un processeur qui soit pas
le S23 une batterie de 3900 millions par
heure ok why not sur le S23 plus 4700 ça
se muscle un peu ça commence à
progresser et puis vous monter jusqu'au
S23 ultra à 5000 milliampères heure
alors comme l'année dernière ils ont
fait le choix de mettre une charge un
peu moins rapide sur l'entrée de gamme
du trio de gamme sur le S 23 on a une
charge 25 watts tandis que sur le S23
plus c'est le S23 ultra on va retrouver
des charges 45 W alors attention on peut
monter jusqu'à 45 W mais sachez que le
bloc de charge n'est pas fourni dans la
boîte pas plus que les écouteurs voilà
ça il faut le savoir le truc est
toujours très très bien ici avec Samsung
c'est l'expérience logiciel one uy alors
je vous avais fait une vidéo il y a
quelques semaines sur One ui à 5.0 on us
5.1 arrive avec de nouveaux widgets
l'interface toujours très clair très
lisible et sympa toujours basé sur
Android 13 et là où Samsung va plus loin
alors nous en fait toute une explication
en parlant effectivement d'un côté
écologique responsabilité produire ses
clés je vous expliquais à la fin de la
vidéo vous allez voir il y a quand même
de très jolis promesses qui sont faites
et ils nous disent on va aller plus loin
au niveau des mises à jour Android vous
aurez cette fois-ci quatre ans de mise à
jour Android et 5 années j'ai
l'impression d'être à Fort Boyard je
fais passe partout 5 années de mise à
jour la sécurité pourquoi pour vous
puissiez garder vos smartphones plus
loin dans le temps en tout cas c'est ce
que vient ici nous raconter Samsung et
ça ne s'arrête pas là
et le truc la gamme de la photographie
avec de très jolies promesses une fois
de plus qui sont faites alors je vous le
donne dans le mille je sais pas si tu as
pris par cœur j'ai mes notes ici on
reprend la même idée qu'on avait sur les
S22 c'est-à-dire un triptyque photo au
niveau des S23 S23 plus vous avez un
capteur principal en grand angle de 50
mégapixels équivalent 20 mm avec un
autofocus dual pixel sur le principe
c'est plutôt sympa ça a l'air d'être
très très cool un ultra grand-angle de
12 mégapixels et on va retrouver un
téléobjectif de 10 mégapixels avec un
zoom optique x 3 ça me plaît ça me botte
bien et avec un zoom numérique jusqu'à x
30 bon fois 30 on va pas y aller ça sera
pas terrible mais en tout cas X3 c'est
plutôt sympa et une caméra de selfie de
12 mégapixels donc ça c'est pour les S23
et S23 plus et sur le S23 ultra là on va
quand même vachement plus loin on va
retrouver un capteur principal de 200
mégapixels qui lui permettra de faire
pas mal de choses si vous avez de très
très belles conditions lumineuses vous
pouvez venir shooter ça bouge pas c'est
stabilisé en 200 mégapixels vous aurez
plein de détails dans l'image et vous
allez pouvoir dire ensuite récupérer des
choses qu'on paye donc faire plaisir
pourquoi pas mais vous pouvez également
descendre grâce à un principe de
regroupement de pixels pixel binding en
les gars pixel en fait vous allez
prendre quatre gros pixels de votre 200
mégapixels et vous faites des gros
pixels pour monter jusqu'à 50 mégapixels
car redescendre jusqu'à 50 mégapixels ou
même pourquoi pas aller jusqu'à 12
mégapixels ça va dépendre des conditions
de luminosité et la promesse qui est
faite et qui est intéressante une fois
de plus ici c'est que Samsung permet
d'aller plus loin au niveau des
conditions de faible luminosité en tout
cas c'est la promesse qui est faite sur
le papier il faut ça vachement
intéressant et en plus une technologie
d'autofocus qui est pas mal c'est le
super quad pixel on verra ce que ça
raconte on verra si ça intéressant en
tout cas sur le papier c'est assez
alléchant en ultra grand-angle également
ici de 12 mégapixels le fameux
téléobjectif de 10 mégapixels avec un
zoom optique x 3 qui va jusqu'à x 30 en
numérique et vous avez un deuxième
téléobjectif de 10 mégapixels qui
permettent cette fois-ci d'avoir un zoom
optique x 10 ça c'est très très bien et
d'aller jusqu'au fameux space zoom de
Samsung x 100 bon le X 100 vous en fait
rien mais si vous voulez vous amuser en
tout cas les faire en fois 30 cette
fois-ci qui sera de bonne qualité on
peut y aller c'est sympa et une caméra
de selfie qui passe cette fois-ci sur le
ultra de 40 mégapixels l'année dernière
à 12 mégapixels on dit c'est parce
qu'ils ont intégré la mise au point dual
pixel bon ok sur le principe soit très
cool très les champs et un autre truc
qui est aussi plutôt cool c'est que sur
les trois smartphones ils viennent
monter au niveau de la vidéo on pourrait
filmer jusqu'en 8k à 24 images par
seconde cette fois-ci c'est du 8k
jusqu'à 30 images par seconde j'ai pris
à la main je l'ai pris en fait moi j'ai
un tremblement essentiel pour vous dire
que les images moi je suis un vrai crash
test pour la stabilisation 8k 30 images
par seconde je tiens comme ça c'est très
très bien stabilisé en tout cas sur ce
que j'ai vu aujourd'hui à voir et a
peaufiner lors des phases de test mais
en tout cas ce que j'ai vu l'homme plaît
beaucoup et le truc est cool c'est
qu'ici ça me saoule est venu optimiser
sa partie photo et surtout vidéo pour
les réseaux sociaux parce que souvent
c'est un peu le parent pop sur Android
vous avez une application et vous avez
plein de constructeurs différents vous
avez plein d'expérience différentes même
si à la base c'est un Android est-ce
qu'il fait qu'à la fin des fois conduite
un peu moyen donc eux ils sont venus
vraiment travailler avec d'un côté
Google toute la partie Android Samsung a
bosser mais également avec les
applications Instagram snapchat snapchat
c'est hyper dur à dire quand même
snapchat et Tik Tok l'idée c'est que
vous ayez un rendu qu'il soit hyper
qualitatif parce que vous allez venir
toucher notamment des vidéos donc ça
déjà c'est vachement cool en plus de ça
et si on veut travailler sur leur
stabilisation optique pour la
compensation du mouvement donc
normalement ça devrait être encore mieux
déstabiliser en tout cas moi ce que j'en
ai vu ça me paraît vachement cool avoir
une fan de plus en le testant un
smartphone qui résiste en bien
évidemment à l'eau et à la poussière
avec une certification
IP68 on a un indice de réparabilité de
8,2 sur 10 ok sur le principe c'est
plutôt cool bien évidemment du NFC pour
le paiement des matérialisé avec
notamment Samsung pay et Google paye et
puis bien évidemment du wifi 6e c'était
déjà le cas l'année dernière avec le S22
ultra on le retrouve ici sur les trois
produits et ça c'est plutôt chouette
Samsung vient nous parler ici de
recyclage de produits recyclés de
développement durable alors avec des
produits qui sont recyclés je vous le
donne dans le mille j'ai noté ici il y a
plus de composants recyclés par rapport
à ce qu'on avait dans les produits avant
on a deux fois plus alors qu'avant on
avait du plastique recyclé c'était déjà
bien cette fois-ci ils vont un peu plus
loin avec de l'aluminium recyclé qu'on
va retrouver sur tout le contour c'est
de l'aluminium Armor en termes de
sécurité et d'ailleurs je sais pas si je
vous l'ai dit j'ai retrouvé un Corning
Aurillac glace victus deuxième
génération à l'avant mais également à
l'arrière et vous avez en plus un verre
qui est recyclé au niveau de votre
Corning gorille la glace Corning Gorilla
glas Vitus monsieur gros travail
addiction et bien à ce moment vous avez
du vert qui recyclé alors pas à 100%
dans l'ordre d'entre 20 et 30% en tout
cas ce recyclage se fait la machine va
en avant et ça c'est plutôt chouette ils
nous disent également qu'il y aura une
élimination des plastiques à usage
unique des 2025 bon on y est pas encore
mais ça va arriver par contre
souvenez-vous si vous avez déjà eu des
smartphones de Samsung ou d'autres
marques lorsque vous l'ouvrez bien vous
aviez un petit film plastique cette
fois-ci ce film plastique était remplacé
par un film en papier c'est plutôt bien
et il y avait un autre truc que je vous
l'avais déjà dit l'année dernière vous
savez lorsque vous venez l'ouvrir et
l'unboxer sur tout le contour au niveau
de l'aluminium vous aviez un peu de
plastoc à venir virer et là cette
fois-ci a priori il l'aurait supprimé ça
me paraît en tout cas dans le bon sens
ces produits vous pouvez les
précommander aujourd'hui et en plus un
truc est très intéressant c'est que à
partir d'aujourd'hui jusqu'au 16 février
et bien vous avez des précommandes avec
des offres plutôt cool et une fois de
plus je vous mets le lien en bas dans la
description un truc qui est très sympa
c'est qu'il vous double le stockage et
oui bien évidemment et en plus c'est
directement
c'est cadeau ça fait plaisir donc si
vous achetez par exemple un ultra et que
vous prenez un 512 PAF vous montez un
terrain si par exemple vous achetez un
S23 plus et vous prenez un 256 PAF vous
montez à 512 c'est magique presque et
ces produits
euros et puis si on veut le must du must
qui se fait le mieux en terme de
stockage performance de puissance et
compagnies 12 Go de RAM 1era à 1839
euros et je vous le dis le bon plan
c'est que si par exemple vous voulez un
S23 ultra et que vous voulez ce qui se
fait de mieux en terme de stockage à 1
To et bien vous achetez dès maintenant
la version en 512 giga de stockage à
1599 € et il vous double le stockage ça
c'est du premier au 16 février je trouve
ça très cool donc dites-moi ce que vous
en pensez comment vous les trouvez c'est
S23 cette année est-ce que vous trouvez
que Samsung a plutôt bien bossé va plus
loin est-ce que vous êtes comme moi
d'accord sur le fait qu'ils aient
incorporé le stand dragon 8 GN2 c'est
une vraie avancée chez Samsung ça va pas
mais vraiment déjà d'être au top au
niveau des benchmarks et de concurrencer
tous les autres on s'achète très très
cool parce que vous en pensez bien
évidemment dans les commentaires est-ce
que vous pourriez craquer si oui sur
lequel modèle et puis bien évidemment on
en parle très bientôt sur la première
prise en main sur les tests sur les
tests 4 mois après sur le test six mois
après allez ça va peut-être voilà je
vous embrasse prenez soin de vous et à
très bientôt Ciao
[Musique]